i know
many of them
she's come to pay her respects not to
forget friends lost since the war broke
out in the east of the country in 2014.
ines arogotska was a volunteer back then
providing support to the soldiers on the
front line
the idea of possible renewed fighting
worries her new of course i think the
world is going
on and on from
2014.
i don't know
will we have
a big war
but
we have guns and we are ready
talk of war and a possible russian
invasion concerns many ukrainians
but people here feel things could be
different this time around
many are grateful of the support some
western countries have provided ukraine
some publicly thanking the uk for its
recent delivery of mid-range weapons
but elsewhere around kiev people are
going about their daily lives wondering
if war is as imminent as their leaders
have been warning
there is also a sense among people here
that the situation is made more
complicated because of the competition
between russia and the west over
influence in this part of the world
ukraine being at the center of it
dmitry sokolov and his wife olena left
crimea soon after russia next the
peninsula in 2014.
like many he thinks that ukraine has
come a long way since
we are different in mentality we were
different we are very much different now
from from russia and we are very much
different from ukrainians that were in
2014. more than 50 percent we
believe that this is just a part of game
like let's say a kind of trading you
know which uh
what states will provide to russia under
pressure
et cetera so we hope it's all
but for katja pushnayanskaya the
problems also come from within she
hasn't returned to her hometown of
luganz since pro-russian separatists
took over
[Music]
the problem is not only russia sometimes
i don't feel part of this country
sometimes my friends and colleagues make
the point that we are guilty of
provoking this conflict i really don't
understand where i belong
eight years on ukrainians have learned
to live with the threat from their big
neighbor
many say it's become part of their lives
but what they fear now is that any move
by russia or the us could bring more
divisions among ukrainians
al jazeera kiev